[Music]
hello Wolfgang if you are like me and
you are seeing Avengers infinity war on
the 26 then we have six days until the
movie comes out woohoo in this video I
wanted to talk about a love story that
you may not know about if you haven't
read the comics and that is the love
between the Scarlet Witch and vision if
you haven't read the comics you probably
noticed them getting closer in Captain
America Civil War and if you were really
paying attention you could have noticed
a little something between them and
Avengers age of Ultron so how does this
love story play out in the comics let's
talk about it before we get started be
sure to subscribe to my channel and join
our team I just thought my own team team
for of course and it would be me and
Daryl just us right dee yep
the movies don't differ too much from
the comics in the comics The Scarlet
Witch and vision both meet when they
joined the Avengers they both eventually
fall in love with each other but there
are some objections from some of the
members the scarlet witch's brother
Quicksilver objects because he can't
handle the fact that his sister is in
love with a robot Clint aka Hawkeye also
objects because in the comics he doesn't
have this loving family that the MCU
shows you know in fact he objects
because he is in love with the Scarlet
Witch himself he even lays the moves on
her at one point kissing her and what
she says I'm kissing you why aren't you
kissing me back and she replies I am
love with vision eventually everyone
becomes okay with it and over time the
Scarlet Witch and vision get married
their love in the comics and from what I
can tell in the movie stems from their
ability to love each other
unconditionally the vision just wants to
know what it's like to be human to love
and feel and Wanda loves him
unconditionally despite him being an
Android and Wanda just wants to be
viewed as a normal person not the
powerful witch that she is vision just
sees a beautiful woman that loves him
and loves her unconditionally in return
eventually the two of them would leave
the Avengers to start their new life
together and enjoy
married life as a couple not having to
worry about taking on supervillains and
saving the world they would then achieve
the impossible by Wanda getting pregnant
this being stunning to both of them
seeing as how Wanda is a human and
vision is an Android they go on to tell
us that it was her magic that made it
happen both her and vision wanting
children so badly it was her hex powers
that made it possible for them to have a
child or two that's right they have
twins okay so a lot of crazy things
happen from here but I don't want to get
too into it because I want to keep it
relevant to what I think we'll see in
Avengers infinity war and Avengers 4
what kind of crazy things you ask well
for starters how about the fact that her
twins are actually shards of the demon
Mephisto and they eventually get
absorbed back into him which causes her
to lose her kids ultimately she goes
crazy and loses her mind and control of
her powers resulting in killing vision
and Hawkeye the Avengers and the x-men
get together and ultimately talk about
killing her because she is so powerful
and out of control Quicksilver finds us
out and convinces her to change reality
to a reality where her Quicksilver and
Magneto ruled the world I know it's
crazy and if you want to know more you
should definitely read the House of M
series I don't think any of this will be
in Avengers infinity war or Avengers 4
though I think it's mostly going to
focus about how they fall in love and
end up together we can tell from the
trailers that they're clearly going to
focus on the romance between vision and
the Scarlet Witch and Avengers infinity
war Wanda beam by visions side and
almost every scene that we've seen
fighting and protecting him they're a
pretty interesting and powerful couple
if you think about it a witch who has
immense power in an Android who has the
power of an infinity stone it'll be
interesting to see these two use their
powers as they fight for each other on
screen not to mention that Thanos and
the children of Thanos will be coming
for the mine stone inside of visions
head so the Scarlet Witch and vision
will have to be on their a-game so this
is just a quick history of the Scarlet
Witch and the vision in the comics
whether you've read the comics or this
is all brand new information to you let
me know what you're most excited to see
with the vision and the Scarlet Witch in
Avengers infinity war and let me know
what you think their story will be an
infinity war do you think they'll get
married and have kids or do you think
vision will die or maybe they'll both
die let me know in the comments below
and if you enjoyed this video
please be so kind and give it a thumbs
up and also subscribe to my channel for
more videos like this and to stay up to
date on Marvel Comics Avengers infinity
war and everything superhero thank you
so much for watching
woof woof oh it's a nice flat as you can
see and uh we get along well yeah I
guess I just wanted to be around average
everyday people and Daryl with an
average sort of everyday guy so it works
out well while I'm here I'm trying to
get involved with the lobbies who's this
purple weirdo surprise who actually knew
that was to give back to the community